this isn't a flight that many had
planned on taking these nigerian
nationals are returning to their home
country but they say it's not by choice
more than 300 people have taken up the
offer of a free flight to repatriate
them from South Africa after a new wave
of violence against foreigners but just
over half boarded the flight others had
expired passports or the wrong documents
and had to stay shops owned by foreign
nationals have been looted and burnt to
the ground
pastor Igor football has lived in South
Africa for close to two decades he says
he's sending his wife and three children
back to Lagos yeah I'm worried about my
family safety in South Africa here now
you got it Easter happens you know
recently is so terrible so I can't risk
my family to be in South Africa for now
I don't think they will be coming back
about 640 people are expected to be
repatriated this is the third time in
recent years there's been significant
unrest between locals and foreigners
adding to tensions between the Nigerian
and South African governments now the
flights are an opportunity for people
seeking safety but many who staying are
uncertain about their future more than
700 people from other countries like
Malawi and Zimbabwe have sought refuge
at community centers many say they don't
feel safe living there anymore
many of the people here fled their homes
in local communities with little more
than a few bags one of them is Muslim
beacon ask us it to where who is
registering to get a temporary travel
document to return home he's lived in
South Africa for 30 years but he lost
everything in the riots being a cell
phone in Iran is that I saw how they we
are taking people are taking them like
stalks and some of the people we are
taking us where people that have known
us for a long time that's what has me
the most
the hundreds leaving maybe a small
portion of the millions of foreigners
living in South Africa but there are
fears the violence will have a great
impact on South Africa's relationship
with other African nations femida mela
al jazeera Johannesburg South Africa